- [Voiceover] How many more bikes does
Bike World have than Bikes R Us?
So let's compare Bike World to Bikes R Us.
So Bike World is right over here
and we see that Bike World,
if we just look at this right over here,
Bike World has 19 bikes,
has 19 bikes.
And they wanted us to compare
Bike World to Bikes R Us
and say how many more
bikes does Bike World have
than Bikes R Us?
So Bike World has 19,
how many does Bikes R Us have?
This is Bikes R Us right over here,
Bikes R Us has,
Bikes R Us has 12 bicycles.
So how many more does Bike
World have than Bikes R Us?
Well we can just subtract
Bikes R Us's number
of bikes from Bike World's, 19 minus 12.
What is that going to be?
Well if we look at the ones place,
nine ones minus two ones is seven ones,
and then one ten minus one ten is no tens.
I could write no tens there
but I don't have to write that.
So there's seven more bikes
at Bike World than Bikes R Us.
And you can also see it here.
If you start at Bikes R Us,
If you were to start at Bikes R Us
and you wanted to go
and you wanted to see how many more bikes
would I have to get to the same number
of bikes as Bike World,
you would see that you would
have to go from 12 to 19,
or you would have to add seven bikes,
or that Bike World has seven
more bicycles than Bikes R Us,
one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So how many more bikes does
Bike World have than Bikes R Us?
It has seven more bikes.